when you think of early modern colonial
empires your mind went often think of
Latvia as being a colonizer yet as will
surprise many of you the Latvians did
give it to go well sort of Latvia
technically didn't exist then instead it
was a territory called core land whose
people the caronian spoke Latvian
barring the mandatory ruling German
minority obviously so what exactly was
core land and what was it like it was
nominally a puppet state of the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth and whilst it's
duke did declare fealty to the king of
poland the Duchy was for the most part
free to do as it pleased it was an
important exporting state to cross the
Baltic Sea and especially given its size
it sported a very impressive Navy as of
the 1640s the caronian CID expanded from
just trading in the Baltics to trading
across the Atlantic and Indian Oceans
there's conflicting accounts of when
they first tried their hand at
colonisation but the Duke of Courland
Jakob Keppler had had a keen interest in
colonisation since the 1630s he'd been
in talks with dutch and swedish bankers
over colonizing the island of Tobago and
had negotiated many trade agreements
with colonial powers in the new world as
such he was confident not only of
getting safe passage there but also of
being able to grow and maintain a
colonial foretold in the Caribbean
Courland made several attempts at
colonizing Tobago in the first likely
occurred in 1639 now they weren't the
first the Spanish the Dutch in English
had all tried before to sester the
island and all had failed hence by
Tobago was known at the time as the
island of despair the English then
approached Jakob and offered him a crack
at it and so Jakob sent over 200 people
mostly criminals to Tobago the natives
attacked the settlement they created and
the colony ended in failure
three years later Jakob gave it another
go this time using Dutch settlers are
much like the first time it failed
things weren't going too well for Jakob
and the caronian but another colonial
opportunity presented itself in 1651
Gambia was taking an active role in the
transatlantic slave trade courland was
granted a small colony in Gambia Bites
king and returned for annual payments
and after this Jakob was sure to push
the idea of maintaining good relations
with the natives
Jakob gave colonizing Tobago one last
try in 1654 but this time he took the
lessons he learned over the previous
decade in half and utilized them
properly first of all he sent over 120
soldiers to Tobago to protect the colony
from both the natives in any foreign
powers second he recruited settlers from
many other nations as well as courland
itself and third he made sure the
efforts were made to accommodate the
natives and they were given legal rights
there the colony was settled by thousand
of people and was renamed new corland
with its capital being Jakob stat the
caronian approaches success is proved by
the fact that within four years the
colony's populations has at twenty five
thousand people with about five thousand
of those being caronian x' the rest had
pledged their loyalty to Jakob and core
London of the twenty five thousand
people who lived there roughly 13,000
were slaves from core lands can be in
colony and so it seemed that the
caronian approach to colonization had
worked which raises the question why
wasn't there a continuous Latvian
speaking population in the Caribbean
then well in 1656 Courland as part of
the numerous ongoing swedish polish wars
was invaded and in 1658 Jakob was
captured whilst he was imprisoned the
Dutch enticed the caronia garrison to
revolt and so Jakob then signed the
colony over to them in 1664 now no
longer able to project power overseas
Colin ceded his Gambian colony to
England and thus the shortly of Latvian
attempt to colonialism was over I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching with extra thanks to these
patrons you can see on screen for their
continued support and an extra special
thanks to James Bissonnette David
archaeologists as ARCA Flash Danny
Maloney party-boy Koch coolin Castleman
Rob Waterhouse Chris wicker Gustav Swan
David Silverman Winston hegwood
Christian checky Maggie packs Kowski
Lexi Schwinn Anthony Beckett Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell Ike spinning three
plates are on the white and Michael
Reynolds